there's nothing quite like a great
science fiction movie and according to
metacritic these are the very best of
the best here's the question though how
many have you seen you've taken your
first step into a larger world star wars
perhaps you've heard of it the 1977
original that we now call a new hope
turned hollywood completely upside down
becoming the highest grossing film of
all time and holding that record until
it was dethroned by et in 1982. the
initial critical response was mixed but
the masses who spoke so loudly with
their wallets have since been vindicated
with near universal acclaim in hindsight
today the movie holds a score of 90 on
metacritic star wars represented a
quantum leap forward in filmmaking
technology dazzling audiences with
visual effects the likes of which they'd
never seen but neat tricks aren't the
only driving force behind director
george lucas's greatest achievement this
is a fictional world that feels so real
that viewers can't help but become
absorbed in it certainly there's no
greater example of science fiction's
escapist appeal or its versatility as a
genre than star wars the movie combines
elements of war epics classic spaghetti
westerns and sword and sorcery fantasy
into a sci-fi setting that really does
have something for everyone
in the future of mad max an ecological
disaster has left earth bone dry and the
survivors of the apocalypse now battle
over the remaining supplies of water and
oil between the 1979 original mad max
and its two sequels in the 1980s each
film in the series upped the ante on
grim yet stylish over-the-top action in
2015 however director george miller took
things to a whole new level with mad max
fury road the fourth film in the
franchise is an intense non-stop chase
movie in which hard luck hero max
rokhtansky teams up with the
devastatingly cool imperator furiosa
together they help five women escape
slavery at the hands of a revolting
despot fury road is a top-notch action
movie with eye-popping stunts and
practical effects and award-winning
costume and production design these
qualities alone were enough to earn it
high praise from critics upon release of
course but fury road has also been held
up as a feminist film too tackling
themes and issues rarely found in action
movies you cannot own a human being
sooner or later someone pushes back
the film's combination of brains
compassion and pure adrenaline led to
the kind of major awards recognition
that genre flicks rarely receive too as
well as a near perfect meta score of 90.
it now stands as an example of how
sci-fi can educate and empower as well
as entertain
not every great science fiction film is
a blockbuster hit indeed russian
director alexi german's 2013 adaptation
of the strogatzky brothers novel hard to
be a god grossed just under 1.3 million
dollars worldwide it is an opaque and
difficult watch even in the eyes of
those who love it av club critic ignati
vishnovetsky wrote if hard to be a god
isn't the filthiest most fetid looking
movie ever made it's certainly in the
top three meanwhile the guardians peter
bradshaw asked in his five-star review
what on earth does it mean but if the
film's metacritic score of 90 is
anything to go by heart to be a god is a
challenge worth accepting the plot reads
like a cautionary tale out of a classic
star trek episode though the novel
predates the series by a few years a
team of scientists is dispatched to an
earth-like planet whose social and
technological development are centuries
behind our own held back by a stubborn
and violent anti-intellectualism the
protagonists are tasked with anonymously
kickstarting the culture's progress an
effort that is repeatedly met with
disaster and disappointment do not
approach hard to be a god expecting
anything conventional the telegraph's
robbie colin warns that the film refuses
to take any recognizably plot-like shape
but assures that an open-minded viewer
will find it quote exhilarating moving
funny
beautiful and unshakeable
in the early 1930s hollywood brought to
life a parade of movie monsters who
remain firmly in the public
consciousness even today but one stands
taller above all the rest
oh no
it wasn't the airplanes
it was beauty kill the beast
king kong was the first great movie
monster to be created solely for the big
screen rather than having been adapted
from literature or mythology and sure
inventing a really big ape may not have
been the wildest leap of the imagination
but the story of the 1933 movie as well
as the technology invented to execute it
has helped the attention of cinephiles
for the better part of a century effect
supervisor willis o'brien brought king
kong's titular character and his
dinosaur foes to life by employing
practically every special effects trick
that had been invented stop motion matte
paintings rear screen projection
miniatures and giant puppets and he
combined them with live action
photography in a more seamless manner
that had ever been seen before king kong
was met with instant critical and
commercial success and despite a string
of sequels remakes and reboots the 1933
original still reigns supreme with its
meta score of 90. viewer beware though
that king kong was very much made in
1933 in the decades since some scholars
and critics have come to see the film as
a racist allegory and while the film's
co-directors denied any such intent it's
certainly not difficult to read it that
way
originally released as a trilogy of
sorts it's such a beautiful day is a
mixed media film built around pen and
paper stick figure animations that
despite their simple forms are
remarkably expressive and sympathetic
the film tells the story of bill a man
coping with a brain disease that is
gradually destroying his memory and
eroding his grip on reality the story is
told in a stream of consciousness style
that takes the audience closely into
bill's thoughts as he examines his life
his family history and the nature of
existence remarkably this animated film
is the product of a single creator don
hertzfeldt from its hand-drawn character
performances to its narration and sound
effects it's such a beautiful day is
also a brutally dark comedy one so dark
that it's actually hard to call it a
comedy at all indeed vultures bill
gabiri calls it one of the saddest films
he's ever seen but nevertheless ranks it
among the best films of the 2010s in a
2020 retrospective biry wrote
herzevelt's attention to the fleeting
glories of existence makes you feel one
with the universe but along with being
profound it's such a beautiful day is
also a deeply intimate film that makes
you empathize with its cruelly drawn
protagonist on a level you might not
think possible it holds a score of 90 on
metacritic where it is also ranked as
the 20th greatest animated film of all
time
in andrei tarkovsky's 1972 film solaris
a psychologist is sent to investigate a
space station whose entire crew has
suffered some sort of emotional
breakdown while initially dismissing the
reports of bizarre visions as mere
hallucinations the psychologist soon
finds himself face to face with his late
wife what is she really has the strange
ocean planet below somehow reunited them
or is she some sort of illusion and even
if she isn't real can't they still be in
love solaris draws easy comparisons to
2001 a space odyssey another slow
deliberate and visually stunning art
film set in space but as roger ebert
wrote in a retrospective review 2001 is
outward charting man's next step in the
universe while solaris is inward asking
about the nature and reality of the
human personality the film has an
intriguing sci-fi conceit in its titular
sentient planet which attempts to
communicate to the humans above using
their own memories but as in most great
speculative fiction the otherworldly
element is just a device through which
to explore a character and by extension
the audience solaris premiered at the
1972 cannes film festival where it won
the grand prix special de jouri and was
nominated for the palmdale an american
remake was also produced in 2002
directed by steven soderbergh but is not
as highly regarded with a meta score of
65 to the tarkovsky version's 90.
in steven spielberg's 1977 movie close
encounters of the third kind electrician
roy neary becomes obsessed with the
search for extraterrestrial life after
having a run-in with a low-flying ufo
neri discovers that he and a number of
other ufo witnesses have been sharing
strange visions leading them on a daring
quest for the truth have you recently
had a close encounter you know i'm
called
a close encounter with something very
unusual
well not a marathon of effects heavy set
pieces like star wars which was released
the same year close encounters
nevertheless features one of the most
arresting finales in sci-fi history
above all this is an adventure story one
that's light on action but heavy on
suspense intrigue and wonder keeping the
story grounded in the point of view of
everyday people in a contemporary review
of the movie gary arnold of the
washington post wrote spielberg seems to
be whispering this is going to scare you
but don't be afraid spielberg puts on an
enchanting magic show springing one
sensuous and sentimental highlight after
another authentic performances
groundbreaking effects and a gorgeous
john williams score have made close
encounters an enduring favorite among
critics and it now boasts a meta score
of 90. the film was nominated for seven
academy awards winning for
cinematography and sound effects editing
in 1980 after seeing spielberg's revised
special edition of the film roger ebert
called it quote one of the great movie
going experiences
many of the highest scoring sci-fi films
on metacritic like to show their
audiences something grand and awe
inspiring but spike jones's 2013 drama
her focuses on something much smaller
your cell phone joaquin phoenix plays a
lonely man who falls in love with
samantha the self-aware operating system
on his phone and computer the film takes
a realistic and down-to-earth approach
to its premise fleshing out the romance
before gradually broadening its scope to
examine the grander implications of
bringing a thinking feeling artificial
intelligence into the world her rings a
lot of humor and pathos out of its
bizarre yet relatable premise raising
questions not only about our culture's
increasing dependence on technology but
also on how we relate to each other as
human beings what do we or should we
look for in love how much of love is
about the other person and how much is
selfish what happens when one partner
needs the other more and all of these
questions are centered around an awkward
introvert and the shiny rectangle he
carries in his pocket brought to life by
terrific committed performances by
phoenix and his co-star scarlett
johansson on top of awarding it a meta
score of 90 metacritic found that her
topped 22 different lists of critics
favorite films of 2013. her was also
nominated for five academy awards
including best picture and brought home
the prestigious oscar for best original
screenplay
few sci-fi films hold such a treasured
place in the hearts of 80s kids as
steven spielberg's e.t the
extraterrestrial released in the spring
of 1982 et was a massive success drawing
in families in such droves that it
supplanted star wars as the highest
grossing film of all time like
spielberg's other sci-fi films et
features moments of eerie suspense and
exciting adventure but it also has
something going for it that most genre
blockbusters don't it's adorable
e
tea home
phone
et tells the story of elliot taylor
played by 10 year old henry thomas and a
benign alien visitor represented by an
advanced animatronic and performed by a
variety of puppeteers and costumed
doctors made long before cgi became the
norm eti is so emotive and charismatic
that it takes no time to forget that
he's just a special effect and when his
time on earth takes a toll on et's
health you'll likely find yourself
genuinely concerned even anguished with
worry over his well-being don't worry
everyone else felt the same way et was a
hit with critics upon its release and
continues to tug on their heartstrings
today in 2012 christy lemire of the
philadelphia inquirer wrote how old is
too old to sob like a little girl at et
the extraterrestrial not 40 apparently
the film holds a meta score of 91.
hailing from thai director apichipong we
receded cool memoria is perhaps one of
the most enigmatic sci-fi films of all
time it debuted in july 2021 at the
cannes film festival where it was
awarded the jury prize one of the events
highest honors but its theatrical
release has been extremely limited still
those critics who have seen it have
heaped praised aplenty upon the film
winning it a meta score of 91 polygon's
robert daniels warns that the movie is a
little metaphor heavy but nonetheless
writes memoria is a sensory explosion
and its dense immersive shrapnel isn't
easily removable memoria is the story of
jessica a scottish woman living in
colombia who is haunted by a thunderous
recurring sound that only she can hear
but this isn't so much a mystery as it
is a character study and existential
meditation all in all memorial may not
be every sci-fi enthusiast's cup of tea
of course but it's a must-see for fans
of arthocinema that is if it's ever
playing near you
mary shelley's 1818 novel frankenstein
has been described as the first true
work of science fiction a tale of
science gone wrong with a strong moral
and emotional core you'll likely know
the story well dr frankenstein attempts
to conquer death by constructing a new
man from the bodies of the dead and
reanimating his tissue via advanced
chemistry
his creature does indeed come to life
but is shunned by society for his
imposing figure and his unnatural
origins leading to a tragic and violent
ending nothing has boosted the cultural
impact of shelley's tales so much as
director james whale's 1931 film
adaptation which redefined the story and
characters of frankenstein into the
iconic tale most familiar to the public
today boris karloff's performance as the
shambling wordless creature as well as
his iconic appearance by makeup artist
jack pierce are now inseparable from the
character later film adaptations
featuring an eloquent intelligent
creature now just feel wrong despite
being more accurate to the source
material karloff even went on to reprise
the role in three sequels frankenstein's
impact on hollywood was felt instantly
in his review for the new york times
morten hall called the film quote far
and away the most effective thing of its
kind nearly a century later critics
still consider frankenstein one of the
pinnacles of both sci-fi and horror and
it stands tall today with a meta score
of 91
virgmeister harmonies is a hungarian art
film from directors belatar and agnes
ranitsky in which the arrival of a
bizarre traveling circus prompts a small
town to descend into madness and despair
the circus is led by a shadowy figure
called the prince whose face is never
shown but whose words propel the
townsfolk towards an unnerving and
inevitable revolution the story is told
from the perspective of a benign and
thoughtful young man who along with his
two elderly uncles becomes the target of
the town's new regime burkmeister
harmonies is 145 minutes long and
contains only 38 cuts apparently if
there weren't physical limitations on
how much film his camera could store at
a time tar claims he would have made
each take even longer these unbroken
shots embed the audience deeply into the
setting and force them to mingle with
the characters even following them
around as they walk silently through the
town for minutes at a time roger ebert
wrote of this style of filmmaking
belatar's style seems to be an attempt
to regard his characters with great
intensity and respect to observe them
without jostling them to follow
unobtrusively as they move through their
worlds which looks so ordinary and are
so awesome like ours while seen by
relatively few film goers burkmeister
harmonies is adored by critics in his
review lawrence van gelder of the new
york times called it quote mysterious
poetic and elusive flowing like a
torturous dream critical consensus has
awarded this film a meta score of 92
science fiction can often be
aspirational showing audiences a future
they'd like to live in and even
suggesting ways they might get there it
can also serve the exact opposite
purpose however warning the public of
the dangers of their current path and
appealing to them to change course
before it's too late threads a
documentary style film produced for the
bbc in 1984 is an unflinching unblinking
portrayal of nuclear war designed for
one purpose to terrify its audience into
action according to a 2009 interview
with the scotsman director mick jackson
claimed he felt the threat of nuclear
annihilation was so enormous that people
lacked the vocabulary to even comprehend
it with threads he hoped to turn his
extensive research into something
visceral and brutal that would help its
audience put words and images to their
fear the story extends far beyond the
events of a nuclear bombing itself into
the months and years that follow
depicting suffering on an unimaginable
scale even decades later threads makes
for one of the most disturbing movie
experiences of all time in 2012 the
guardians peter bradshaw wrote the only
film i have been really and truly scared
and indeed horrified by is mick
jackson's post-nuclear apocalypse movie
threads this visceral look at an
alternate past and a potential future
scores a 92 rating on metacritic
in the 1950s alien invasion stories were
all the rage in hollywood and for
obvious reason too it was the nuclear
age a time when the wonders of outer
space felt closer than ever as did the
threat of conquest by those devious
soviets extraterrestrials on film became
a way to personify this cultural anxiety
or to criticize it depending on who you
ask the original 1956 version of
invasion of the body snatchers does both
or neither
invasion of the body snatchers is a
thriller following two suburbanites who
discover that their neighbors are being
secretly replaced one by one with
identical copies of alien origin bent on
world conquest the tension grows as they
begin to question whether there's anyone
left in town who are still who they
appear to be jack finney the author of
the novel on which the film is based
claimed that there was no political
purpose behind his story at all but the
film is nonetheless soaked in the
paranoia of its day timeout's 2014
retrospective review explains from
fascism to communism to capitalist
conformity this is the perfect
distillation of uncanny existential
terror critics thought little of
invasion of the body snatchers in 1956
but generations later it has risen to a
meta score of 92.
wally is a visually stunning computer
animated film with a heart of gold and
something truly worthwhile to say the
brainchild of director andrew stanton
and the celebrated pixar animation
studio wally's titular character is one
of earth's last living inhabitants and
has one programmed purpose to crush
garbage into compact stackable cubes
after years in isolation however he
grows beyond his programming dreaming of
romance and adventure wally gets his
wish when he discovers a living plant
among the ruins of our spoiled planet
and falls in love with eve the advanced
probe tasked with returning the plant to
humanity's new home in space throughout
their journey the film dazzles with
beautiful animation and production
design and comments on modern
consumerism and reliance on technology
all the while remaining a romantic
comedy at heart wally drew instant
critical acclaim upon its release new
york magazine's david edelstein wrote
the new pixar picture wall-e is one for
the ages a masterpiece to be savored
before or after the end of the world it
was nominated for seven academy awards
winning best animated feature and with a
meta score of 95 ranks in metacritic's
top 10 animated features of all time
director james wales frankenstein
shocked new life into both horror and
science fiction in 1931 but it's his
sequel 1935's the bride of frankenstein
that stands as his true masterpiece it
now holds a meta score of 95 besting the
original by four points in bride of
frankenstein dr frankenstein's mentor dr
pretorius coerces him into harvesting
more dead bodies with which to create a
mate for the lonely creature she's alive
meanwhile the creature wanders the
countryside searching for meaning or
companionship only to have it stolen
from him at every opportunity by
closed-minded citizens the bride of
frankenstein builds on the horror of the
first film while also adding a charming
sense of self-awareness and humor whale
minds both scares and laughs from the
creatures misadventures and dr pretorius
is camp incarnate the film is also full
of moments and images that have since
become so iconic that some may assume
they originated in the previous films
such as the creature's grunts and broken
speech or his friendly encounter with
the blind hermit the bride herself with
her statically charged hairdo is one of
the most famous figures of the genre
despite only appearing briefly in the
film initially praised as merely a
first-rate horror film the bride of
frankenstein is now regarded as a true
classic of the genre
people want movies to take them places
and that goes doubly for sci-fi movies
the 2013 movie gravity takes its viewers
to the deadly and beautiful reaches of
earth's orbit and then holds them there
relentlessly for about 90 minutes the
film stars sandra bullock as dr ryan
stone an astronaut whose spacewalk is
interrupted when a sudden barrage of
orbital debris destroys her shuttle
alone in the vacuum of space dr stone
must find a way to rendezvous with
another craft before her air runs out or
the debris field comes back around
director alfonso caron took great pains
to keep the audience totally immersed in
the events of the film the story plays
out in just about real time and with as
few cuts as possible in particular
gravity begins with a 13-minute
continuous take that sets the tone for
the entire film in which the camera
floats through space and rarely leaves
ryan's side the technological challenges
of creating gravity meant it took over
four years to complete and the final
product stands up as one of the greatest
examples of what imax 3d can bring to a
film much of what you see in the movie
is computer generated but bollocks
performance is very real and it even
earned her an academy award nomination
for best actress the film would go on to
win seven oscars including best director
for kuron and maintains an astronomical
meta score of 96
with a meta score of 98
metacritic's highest scoring science
fiction film dates all the way back to
1927 during the first golden age of
cinema the brainchild of german director
fritz lang and novelist they van harbu
metropolis is a story of conflict
between the suffering workers and the
pampered ruling class of a massive
futuristic city much of the story
centers around frederick the son of the
city's master who joins with the workers
when he learns of their plight the star
of the show however is bridget helm in
the dual role of maria the kindhearted
leader of the workers and the
machininmensch the wicked robot created
in her image to incite a war between the
factions metropolis wasn't exactly a
critical smash when it was first
released though new york times film
critic mordon hall wrote it is a
technical marvel with feet of clay a
picture as soulless as the manufactured
woman of its story but later generations
were kinder to the film fixating on its
revolutionary special effects and unique
production design scarcity also
contributed to the legacy of metropolis
as only abbreviated cuts were available
for most of the 20th century its 2003
restoration was celebrated by modern
film critics however leading to its near
perfect metascore check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you